the hot shorts have been hung up
Williford
wanted to be bad in 2001 but fast
forward to 2019 if you would have asked
me 18 years ago would I be sitting here
talking about interior design I would
have said Yeah right this is a hamper
they're just like finishing pieces are
you or what I was missing in this whole
scenario main finally found me
yep that's Scott Disick asking Willeford
design advice on flip it like Disick a
new reality series where we'll see the
Lord and his team go to work flipping
houses how do you get involved in the
Scott Disick inner circle you in the
Kardashian Mommy and Me Club yeah no I'm
not and randomly I had helped him a
friend had recommended me to do a couple
things at his house I helped him with
that stuff this is a little while back
and then when this came up
he knew that he needed somebody and he's
like you know I worked with Williford he
was an interior designer now and my name
started to come up in the conversation
he called me and said would you be
interested in talking about this and
that's just the rest sort of just as
history you friendly at all with
Kourtney I know Khloe's gonna be on yeah
I mean really
I spend most of my time with Scott you
can say what you want about any of it
but I do think that that family sticks
together in a really interesting way and
they lift each other up which is very
cool and you see his kids in his
beautiful relationship their modern
family that him and Kourtney have
created it's really awesome
yeah I mean I think people really need
to see this because they see everything
that they had they went through and the
bottom of the barrel and then they see
where they are now and I think parents
need that aren't together anymore need
to see this because it's very important
for the children you can't predict what
can go wrong with the house I'm very
proud of me I was doing interior design
just to fill my soul because I loved it
but there was a moment when I decided I
wanted to be in control of the yes and
the no that was said to me and with
acting and music there was always a
gatekeeper and bye-bye starting my own
business and being an entrepreneur I was
now my own gatekeeper it was really a
no-brainer for me to just completely
pivot because I knew something was
missing in my soul what was it that was
that was missing that I know your
subject
did singer dancer actress yeah why did
that stop fulfilling you I think I think
when you create sometimes it can get
stifled and the love of the create
itself can be gone sure and so for me
when I go into a home and I'm creating
that home nobody was stifling my
creativity and I think I just go to bed
at night seeing this masterpiece that I
know I've given this family and and I
also think the act of serving you know
guess when I was writing more music I
think I was serving more people but I
wasn't seeing it directly right you
didn't know that I was at home and my
bed rag copying the choreography right I
didn't but now I see how it impacts a
whole family and that that take away
from me it's so beautiful that I feel
really really fulfilled I mean normally
we work up to a project for two months
so right so you figure you do this like
a week you're a part of this reality TV
landscape yeah any apprehension about
that it's a lot to have cameras invade
your life yeah there was a lot of
apprehension I had built this company
stepped out of the limelight living this
like really normal life and then when
Scott called me and asked me if I would
be a part of this I thought this is
going to be like a really big commitment
for my whole family
so really we sat down as a family and we
talked about it we're Christians we
prayed about it was this something that
we felt like was good for our marriage
with this something good for our family
and after you know a long discussion we
both felt like we're in a place where we
feel solid in our foundation and it was
time and it was okay to let people in on
that my husband and my son are
off-limits on any TV shows okay so
that's just completely off the table see
them at all they're private this is
Lourdes I could sitting there okay my
throne and my cup of sparkling water do
you have a regal name now I know he's
the Lord so what's going on in the
Lord's life being royal is that yes at
one point he says you are now a lady
properly at the proper lady which
whatever that means fantastic I love it
[Music]
the last thing that you dropped was in
2004 yeah which in my humble opinion was
too long ago the fans want more you know
is there a chance we'll get more not
right now okay yeah I mean the thing is
is anybody that's an entrepreneur knows
I mean getting physical time getting a
business off the ground is pretty
intense my husband travels a lot for
work I also am a mom to a two and a half
year old if you would have asked me 18
years ago would I be sitting here
talking about interior design I would
say yeah right you're crazy so maybe in
20 more years when I'm a little older